Mr President why are you losing to Trump
in the
polls Joe Biden with a stunned look on
his face how can they tell after a car
plowed into his presidential motorcade
it happened right outside his campaign
headquarters in Delaware it was
accidental and they charged the driver
with the DUI but that crash is not the
only thing rattling the big guy
President Biden reportedly lashing out
at his staff over his nose diving poll
numbers a new report claims that after
Biden pardoned the Thanksgiving turkey
he chewed out his underlings over why
Americans hate him and his economic
message speaking of which 57% disapprove
of the job Joe's doing and Biden's
former boss Barack Obama is Raising
concerns that Joe could lose in the
2024 election at least they weren't
carjacked Dana
I mean there's always a silver lining
well because the chances are yes exactly
indeed that was very strange I also
think that the Secret Service I know
they do a very a great job of protecting
everyone but it did seem like took like
two beats too long to like throw the
president in the car because a good way
to have an ambush would be to have
something to have something like that
happen turns out the guy was drunk and
is now um going to probably have a very
Hefty legal bill as he tries to fight
that as to the president calling his
staffers in after pardoning the church
they probably wanted to get pardoned
after that meeting because he does have
a apparently has a temper but the way I
read the article was not so much that he
was mad at them but that he's concerned
that they're not doing anything about it
my concern is for the staffers because
what are they supposed to do one they
made a big mistake and embracing the
phrase bionomics they tried to make that
work it did not work they must have
thought the economy was going great you
could read any mainstream media article
about how Americans just seem to not
understand how great the economy is why
don't they feel so good about it um the
other thing is in the recent polls he's
even underwater on an issue like climate
change so even though he's gotten so far
to the left it's never going to be
enough for them and then that has become
a vulnerability for him not just with um
Democrats but with independent voters as
well on the Barack Obama thing if you
read the article it says that a person
familiar with Barack Obama's thinking
said that he's concerned that Biden
could lose that's really only two
possible people it's either Obama
himself saying you can quote me on the
record a person familiar with my
thinking or it's somebody extremely
close to him who said you have my
permission to put this out there right
so that might be because last week there
was these Democrats saying oh why AR you
doing anything you have to get this
campaign going and it might be a way for
him to kind of put a Log on the Fire ah
so to speak we're out of the a block
enough puns um Katie uh this guy was
charged with a DUI yeah um but shouldn't
we be sympathetic to his
addiction I mean maybe he's trying to
get his life together maybe yeah yeah if
it were Hunter they would they would
make that argument but what can you
imagine being that guy like thinking
you're just going to get home slowly and
you crash into the presidential
motorcade in wilington Delaware not
great for him but in terms of Biden
being upset about his poll numbers look
he doesn't show up he doesn't show up
for press briefings he doesn't show up
for press announcements he doesn't sell
his own product he's hardly campaigning
you see all these stories about how the
Biden campaign isn't actually doing much
in the states where they need to be
campaigning really hard they're taking
for granted that they're going to win
these swing States and now new polling
shows Trump beating him in pretty much
all of these places they've assumed that
these far left mandates would just be
accepted like the electric vehicle
mandate for example in places like
Michigan because Joe Biden agrees with
the working class and as bluecollar Joe
from Scranton none of that's working and
instead of being at the White House
working on these things or out in the
country really selling them inste in a
genuine organic way everything is very
calculated and scripted and he just
doesn't show up and you can't really
expect people to be buying your product
if you're not the one selling it m
biomics has become Hy nomics it's Hy
nomics yeah Jesse uh this motorcade
accident is an obvious metaphor for his
administration which is why I give it to
you care to expand and on this analogy I
was going to say that Paul Pelosi's DUI
proved that if you're a Democrat who
wrecks his car doesn't really count so
this guy should be off scotf free with a
misdemeanor it is symbolic of this
presidency and then he's blaming the
staff which I love to do yeah I've made
it an art form but you can't blame the
staff when you hired the staff and you
can't blame the staff to sell your
policies when they're your policies
Katie's right this guy doesn't get out
there in the bully pulpit and sell the
policies first the policies should sell
thems but Joe Biden was off today he was
off yesterday he was off Saturday he was
off Friday he just took a 4-day weekend
why do you expect this thing going off
the rails he's facing an impeachment
inquiry his son's facing prison time we
got two proxy wars everything's
expensive and we just set the alltime
American records for homelessness
overdoses and suicides
and he's wondering why things aren't
looking so good Trump is up three and a
half points in the real clear average
Greg that hasn't happened to a
republican candidate in 20 years not
since bush in ' 04 was up three and a
half over John krey not Mccain not
Romney not Trump last two elections he's
cruising right now it looks like a
landslide if it was held today Jessica
impossible to refute yes impossible care
to refute I'm going to give it at the
old College try so Mr Red Wave of the
midterm don't bring that up well you
walked right into subject you keep you
keep giving it to me like on a silver
platter um Democrats are feeling down
it's irrefutable right now it's the one
time that I think actually majority of
the pieces that are coming out are
actually representing what is going on
behind closed doors in these
conversations it doesn't mean that
there's some Mass Exodus and Ry was up
five points on Barack Obama not an
election year well at exactly the same
time we fact checked it how dare you no
you did well you need new fact Checkers
Johnny keep your job brain how dare you
talk about your own colleagues like that
way to blame the staff yeah cardens
blaming the staff staff oh oh jeez I'm
sorry we never going to get through it
but
I so these pieces that are coming out
about you know the problems with the
Phantom campaign and I saw like when I
was going home from work on Friday I saw
this you know big big Biden campaign
announcement they named who is going to
be heading up the Nevada operation a
state that we absolutely need to win and
more of those are going to happen but I
do understand and we have so much
footage that we show on a daily basis of
of Joe Biden that he must be out there
you know he's going to these plants that
he's opening he's talking about what
he's done for the inflation reduction
act the infrastructure act Etc and if
you look at just the headlines of this
with unemployment this low gas prices
going down progress on inflation the Dow
Jones Just Busted two days in a row of
breaking records and his approval on the
handling of the Israel Hamas war is
actually very high I do think it's his
staffer fault at least to the to the
point that they are not saying to him go
be yourself because that's how Joe Biden
won in 2020 right he was the empathetic
nice guy that went over to little kids
in the audience and talk to them about
their stutters and how he got past his
and that's but that's the same exact
thing that everyone always says remember
for Obama when Robert Gibbs said Obama
was so looks so uh demoralized on the
campaign plane he said you know what he
just needs to go out and be himself then
we had the whole thing let Trump be
Trump then Biden I think it is very
different when he goes out he is not
selling the thing he actually had to
have zalinski leave the war zone come to
America to try to convince American
lawmakers that they should Pony up the
money because he can't make the sale but
zalinsky is also desperate to be ble to
have that opportunity and relishes that
opportunity as well and I would just say
that part of what is so upsetting to Joe
Biden right now and I understand it is
he's looking at the other guy and you
say he's up three and a half points here
in the real CER politics average you're
running against a guy who's facing 91
felony counts who in a rally this
weekend says that migrants are poisoning
the blood of the country and is calling
for a reinstatement of his Muslim ban
now I I don't want to get into that is
he actually echoing Hitler yeah a little
bit that's how Hitler talked about Jews
with the dirty blood stuff but the point
is the point is that if your campaign
was going well that person would not be
anywhere near you in the polls and
that's where the frustration comes from
well he's the worst president we've ever
had that's just objectively not true
well I'm just saying if I mean that's
I'm going by your logic if if his
Challenger can say those things and be
ahead he has to be the worst president
ever no prove me wrong where is your
data H what it's all over my
page coming up up next Los Angeles da
George gasone taking his radical softon
crime agenda to the next level by
promoting a far-left crazy who once
called cops Barbarian hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else